Archy squealed Hiram's plan was revealed
and chick's identity is concealed all
that rhyming goodness and so much more
on Sweetwater secrets things are heating
up in Riverdale and I'm not just talking
about Cheryl and Toni's chemistry
country a river babes I'm your host
Liana Galera and this is your after-show
for episode 215 chapter 28 there will be
blood
it was another sensational week because
so much happened in this episode so
let's dive right into all the drama with
the top headlines in the blue and gold
breakdown all right guys
now first Riverdale is in need of a new
mayor and according to the lodges Fred
Andrews would be an ideal candidate they
want my dad to run for mayor it's
business and politics Archie they go
hand in hand
not wanting his father to become the
lodges latest political puppet
Archie decided to share some secrets
with Jughead in hopes that Nancy Drew's
vu would uncover Hiram's master plan for
buying up the whole town he bought the
diner and juggy
did it turns out Hiram wants to bring
organized crime to Riverdale and turned
South Side High into a prison oh and
that big so del project would be housing
for all the people who worked at the
prison now as you can imagine Fred
wanted nothing to do with this dark plan
so the lodge is quickly found a new
candidate to endorse for mayor your next
mayor of Riverdale
my mother Hermione Lodge next up
Clifford blossom left a mysterious
secret will because of course he did
does this mean we're gonna be rich again
and at the public will reading it was
revealed that half of Clifford's fortune
will be divided amongst anyone in town
who can prove that they have an ounce of
blossom blood in their veins and the
rest goes to Cheryl that is until a
surprise guests crash the party turns
out Clifford blossom had an identical
twin because of course he did and he's
back in town for good and causing chaos
and lastly Polly returns again only this
time she's brought her chub Alicia's
twins and met her long-lost brother
chick chick
creepy but wait is chick really a Cooper
now when chick refused to get his DNA
tested so he could snag some of Clifford
blossoms inheritance daddy did some
digging
literally and tested a piece of chicks
used dental floss well turns out this
disgusting side project paid off
big-time because Betty confronted chick
with the truth you're not who you say
you are chick oh and for the record
today I'm channeling both the Cooper
girls as the inspiration for my look
hence the half-up hairdo and mutual
disdain of chick and now for this week's
seven seconds in heaven now after last
week's sexiest episode of Riverdale yet
[Laughter]
things were understandably cooler on the
relationship front and by cool I meant
the weather in Varkey land was downright
chilly now when Archie finally stood up
for himself against Ronnie's mayoral
meddling Veronica tried to protect her
relationship from her parents
manipulating ways but that quickly ended
when we discovered that Archie told
Jughead about Hiram buying puffs I'm
gonna kill you but now that hermione is
running for mayor against Fred and
Archie has pledged his allegiance in
blood to Hiram Lodge I have no clue what
this will mean for var cheater in this
cross town candidate chaos but we'll
just have to find out together now
things seem a ok with bug head and as
much as I'm loving the slow burn of
Shoney's blossoming relationship I
really did not appreciate that weird
travel comment from uncle blossom I came
upon the most wonderful island lesbos
you know I think it was supposed to be
funny or maybe a sly hint of acceptance
but I just found it strange what did you
think hit the comments below and tell me
and now it's time for my favorite
segment hisses and kisses kicking things
off with hisses yeah that way is going
straight to check for lying about his
identity who are you chick and I'm also
sending you a hysteria Polly and her
twins so badly that she decided to leave
town again I am so tired of this Cooper
sister disappearing act I just can't
yeah also once again has anyone heard
from Reggie is anyone concerned has
anyone sent out a search party I'm
starting to get upset do you even go to
this school pisses to Betty for being
Kevin sage mom and pimping him out to be
chicks undercover webcam spy I know your
intentions were good be but that was
just really weird to watch this is to
Archie for his super creepy blood oaths
to Hyrum Lodge I really don't get you
anymore red and his sister Hal Cooper
for trying to block Alice out of the
blossom inheritance and - Penelope
blossoms were being straight-up rude to
tony and conspiring against Nana Rose in
fact this is getting out of control now
raise your hand if you've been
personally victimized by Penelope
blossom luckily my first kiss is going
straight to Alice Cooper for publicly
putting Penelope in her place shut your
face you have melted 10-cent trollop
kisses to Hermione for standing up for
her daughter against Hiram's wrath and
to the return of Smithers I loves the
fact that he's still got these best
interests at heart kisses to Fred
Andrews for being so damn adorable 2fp
Jones for standing by juggy side and to
Archie's workout routine is this
Riverdale or arrow and there you go
alright River babes you know the drill
hit the comments with your hisses and
kisses from the episode and tell me your
thoughts on the latest Riverdale
shockers who do you think chick really
is why would Archie agree to a lodge
family blood oath and did anyone else
find the lesbos comment bizarre what a
weirdo then tune into next week
Sweetwater preview show for episode 2 16
chapter xxix primary colors to see and
your comment is featured in the episode
as always please give this video a like
hit subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel
and then chat with me on twitter
whenever you'd like about all things
Riverdale kisses to you river babes
[Music]